e
estoy feliz de anunciar un acuerdo
histórico serbia y kosovo se unieron de
cara a normalizar sus relaciones
económicas por sesión después de varios
años de conflicto y dos días de
discusiones el presidente serbio a la
izquierda y el primer ministro de kosovo
a la derecha firmaron un acuerdo
económico un texto que debería facilitar
de manera importante el comercio y los
traslados entre los dos estados pero
aunque los líderes se felicitan en
belgrado atracciones son más moderadas
intentan presentar este acuerdo como
algo muy importante pero de hecho no
representa nada porque en principio los
problemas políticos no se han resuelto
de hecho en el plano diplomático las
relaciones entre los dos territorios son
mucho más tensas serbia se niega a
reconocer la independencia de kosovo una
independencia proclamada en 2008 después
de un primer intento en 1990 una guerra
que ha dejado más de 13.000 muertos
seguida de una intervención militar de
la otan
se trata de un acuerdo verdaderamente
pragmático sobre la economía
del gasto
pero el objetivo final es conseguir que
los líderes políticos se tomen en serio
la cuestión de la normalización de sus
relaciones diplomáticas y del
reconocimiento mutuo
pero el camino para una solución
política se muestra lejano para lograr
donald trump esta nueva victoria
política
el mandatario se habría comprometido a
aumentar la inversión estadounidense en
la región